7 p.m
8 p.m
this is how irish night out are now over
at eight until at least the end of
january
for me it doesn't bother me i'm happy
enough to have a few points and leave at
eight o'clock but for younger people
it's much more difficult i think do you
think people just drink in houses now oh
absolutely i don't see people are people
are going to be in a situation where
they have no
there's no kind of
barriers or restrictions or anything
holding people back people are going to
be absolutely hammered in gaffes and
just spreading it even further is that
what you're doing now i i will be doing
it though that's the worst part sorry
about this
republicans say they've been left
bewildered by the new restrictions
no
literally a couple of minutes after
eight o'clock christmas week and it's
completely deserted
yeah it's just surreal uh i've done some
strange things in my time but that's
right up there i mean it just feels kind
of ridiculous it feels pointless it
feels wrong
and uh very it's actually very upsetting
just knowing your business is just
getting destroyed slowly but surely
the new rules have been put in place
because of the rise of omicron which in
the space of just two weeks has
overtaken delta to become ireland's
dominant strain the government has
warned of record case numbers in the
coming days as it urges people to get
their booster shots but once again the
hospitality industry feels it's being
made an easy scapegoat we feel pretty
devastated to be honest
in the dublin suburbs republican deirdre
devitt has spent tens of thousands of
euro on outdoor seating a coffee van and
filtration systems but now she's going
to be hit hard in the pocket again
the bar here opens at 12. it's opening
from 12 to 8 pm viable for you
we have absolutely no idea steven if
it's viable because we don't know what's
coming we're one of the most social
countries in the world every celebration
is had in pubs and restaurants and
hotels and and you know there's pubs
friends of mine pubs and restaurants
that are empty and it's christmas week
we cannot continue like this shutting up
by 8 pm may kill the christmas spirit
for punters but it's the businesses that
are really suffering despite renewed
financial supports from government irish
pubs and restaurants simply can't afford
to keep opening and closing nearly two
years on they say there's still no plan
for truly living with covid
stephen murphy sky news in dublin